in Frank Herbert's dune saga X is the
ninth planet in the alkaloid star system
the Ixion technocracy maintains supreme
control over the world the planet
derives its name from the Roman numeral
9 which marks it as the ninth planet the
exeunt economy relies on the
manufacturing of complex machinery which
on occasion broke the restrictions set
in place by the Butler in Jihad which
stated that no machine could be created
which imitated the human mind though the
ex Ian's often pushed or broke the ban
on artificial intelligence desire for
Nixie and products throughout the
Imperium mostly kept them one step ahead
of invasion by the Great Houses X is the
leading provider of technology in all
the Imperium and exceed devices are
commonplace and considered essential
throughout the series though XE and
devices are common in the series the
society itself is not seen until the
later books in the original saga the
term shine sansho was the word the Ixion
is used to refer to the religion of MU
Adeeb once the jihad had been released
the term seems to indicate that the
Exxon's originated from some oriental
culture likely Chinese moola Deeb's
religion had another name now
it was Shaheen sansho an X in label
which designated the intensity and
insanity of those who thought they could
bring the universe to paradise at the
point of a Kris knife but that too would
change as X had changed for they were
merely the ninth planet of their Sun and
had even forgotten the language which
had given them their name during the
time of the first dune novel the IXY ins
were the most successful fringe world
maintained by a technological base other
than the Binet laylax during the famine
times after the death of the god Emperor
Leto the second the IXY ins became a
major faction of the society which
formed they were the first to
manufacture no ships which contained
machines which imitated the powers of
Guild navigators this broke the guilds
monopoly on
spice these no ships also contain no
chambers which were able to hide people
within from prescient vision the Ixion
ships were also much cheaper than
traditional spaceships this XE an
invention field the scattering the event
in which humans spread beyond the
reaches of the Imperium in heretics of
doom and chapterhouse doom though the XE
ins are at the height of their power the
Bene Gesserit sisterhood viewed them as
a failing power believing that no great
inventions had come out of the IXY and
workshops for centuries the sisterhood
also believed that the bureaucracy that
was now their society would be their
undoing when the honored matras returned
from the scattering and conquer the old
Empire the Bene Gesserit are proven
correct when the ex Ian's are reduced to
a hardly permitted technological combine
the fall of the IXY and power was
ensured by late till the second the god
emperor of doom later the second had
foreseen a future in which the ex Ian's
would release a self-improving hunter
seeker they would lose control and
eventually it would consume all organic
life in the known universe through his
golden path which will be discussed in
greater detail in the ultimate guide to
God emperor of doom Leto prevented the
ex Ian's from being the cause of
humanity's destruction in the extended
dune universe by Brian Herbert and Kevin
J Anderson it was revealed that the
planet X was originally known as Road l9
at the time of the but Larry and jihad
which took place 10,000 years before the
events of the original novel it is
explaining that the family of titans ERK
seas had originally ruled X the Titans
were a group of cyborgs in the legends
of doom trilogy they extended their
lives indefinitely by installing their
brains into walking machine bodies they
used Thinking Machines to subjugate and
enslave humanity until eventually they
were overthrown by a powerful AI known
as M Gnaeus Xerxes took control and
changed the name of the planet
Rodell nine to just X after taluk one of
the original Titans conquered the old
Empire after the fall of the Titans at
the hands of omnious X became one of the
synchronized worlds one of over 500
planets under total machine control in
which their former human populations had
either been enslaved or killed X is
finally liberated in the novel by the
army of the jihad in 175 BG the extended
dune universe is controversial and not
considered as canon by some fans of the
original doom saga the excellent Society
is the best example of a technocracy
within the dune universe although the
Binet laylax may also fall into that
category
a technocracy is the government or
control of society or industry by an
elite of technical experts stay tuned at
the end of this video for a sneak peek
to the ultimate guide to dune Messiah
I wrote the doom series because I had
this idea that charismatic leaders ought
to come with a warning label on the
forehead may be dangerous to your health
one of the most dangerous presidents
that we've had in the century was Jack
Kennedy because people said yes sir mr.
charismatic leader what do we know next
and we wound up in Vietnam and I think
probably the most valuable president of
this century was Richard Nixon because
he taught us to distrust government and
he did it by example well anyway I
wanted to do this thing about messiahs
and charismatic leaders why do 900
people go to Guyana and drink poison
kool-aid why do the citizens of an
entire nation most of the citizens
anyway say Sieg Heil and murder some
three million Jews and Gypsies why do
they not question their leaders
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]